the box icebox is the worst map in the
game and it's not even look and anyone
who says otherwise is just wrong it is
an overwatch map that someone said why
don't we play counter-strike on this i
don't hate a lot of things in life
demandry i
hate attacking on this map d tier 100
percent is two tier haven i used to hate
haven a lot more than i hate it now it's
so easy to over rotate it and that's
kind of like you're like all right like
here
breeze breeze is
breeze is an aimer's map it's literally
valor it's dust too you just have to win
your ones the reason i don't like breeze
is because it feels exhausting to play
with how big it is but it's my second
favorite map in the game because i don't
like it does not mean it's not aids here
all right last one split i think now
split is
top three i think it is a very good like
all-rounder if you will to be good at
split you sort of just have to be good
at valerian
i think it's ageir